(upbeat music)
Upcycling is the latest environmentally friendly trend
currently taking over the fashion world.
What is upcycling you ask?
I have the same questions,
and to find out we've teamed up with our friends at LG
who know a thing or two about clothing care.
Hi Nicole I'm so excited to meet you.
I'm kind of star struck, I'm not kidding.
I am one of your biggest fans.
First of all, I think if you look up
the definition of cool in the dictionary,
your picture is probably there.
Oh my gosh.
What to you is upcycling?
Upcycling is taking materials
and things that already exist in our world today
and creating it into something new
to maximize it and give it longevity.
Upcycling can be taking a garment
and totally reinventing it.
And today you're going to take this sweatshirt
and make it into a bag?
Yes, to keep it from going into landfills,
we have to find creative solutions for it.
LG is creating awareness of how to care for clothes
because they're giving us the opportunity to wash things
and take care of our clothing
so it'll create another life for them.
I'm obsessed with the LG WashTower
and LG Styler Steam Closet in our dressing room.
And I actually used the WashTower
to clean this sweatshirt that Nicole and I will upcycle
into something great for the summer.
We're going to crop the sleeves off of it
and take the excess,
and turn that into a little matching bag.
(upbeat music)
Now we have our summer bag.
It's so cute it like hurts.
I love that you chose like that adorable mint green.
To learn more about how you can give
a second life to your clothes
and get some clothing care tips
check out LGsecondlife.com.
Thank you.
(upbeat music)